[Música]
las explosiones acuden la capital de
Sudán jartum por tercer día mientras
prosigue la violenta lucha por el poder
entre el ejército nacional y el grupo
paramilitar fuerzas de apoyo rápido Far
millones de civiles están atrapados en
el fuego cruzado se ven obligados a
quedarse en casa pero incluso Allí están
inseguros ahmed es ingeniero en jartum
su familia estaba durmiendo cuando un
proyectil alcanzó su casa
estaba durmiendo de repente oí un montón
de sonidos fuertes como balas y cohetes
no sé de qué se trata no puedo salir de
casa Afuera es muy peligroso los
militares están por todas partes no sé
por qué están allí
los médicos advierten que los combates
hacen que el traslado de los heridos al
hospital sea demasiado peligroso
el conflicto afectará sin duda la vida
de muchas personas incluido nuestro
equipo médico
nos han dicho que permanezcamos en
nuestro campamento todas las carreteras
están cerradas la situación es muy
preocupante
el domingo ambas partes acordaron un
alto el fuego temporal para permitir la
evacuación de heridos según las Naciones
Unidas fue parcialmente respetado los
combates también han estallado fuera de
la capital Incluso en la conflictiva
región occidental de darfur ambos bandos
afirman tener el control de lugares
clave como el aeropuerto y el Palacio
presidencia Y ambos se culpan mutuamente
de los combates los militares han estado
al mando de ciudades de un golpe de
estado en 2021 cuando trabajaban con la
Far pero los planes de integrar al grupo
paramilitar en el ejército han provocado
tensiones entre ambos líderes al burján
y
voces internacionales han hecho un
llamamiento al diálogo y al fin
permanente de la violencia pero por
ahora los dos generales no parecen estar
dispuestos a sentarse en la mesa de
diálogo